does he have the same tattoo that uh
conor mcgregor has
oh wow what do you think he did it
because of conor mcgregor do you think
conor mcgregor ever looks and goes
all right mate
well that's english yeah he's from
dublin right he's like okay there you go
hold on hold on i'll get it all right
i'm ready oh top of the bone do you okay
do you think conor mcgregor was like
wait start me on a conor mcgregor accent
real quick uh wait wait he would get
i'm not here to take over i'm here to
take part
home
you sound like uh you sound like beast
oh yeah
patty daddy and i are in the same
[ __ ] boat i identify with i identify
with fighters so often
because patty the batter is like
scousers don't get knocked out and i'm
always like i'll never quit drinking yes
one day patty and i are going to be in a
hospital bed next to each other going
turns out this liver does give up no do
you know him at all no i love that you
two together would be insane we we have
the same we have the same uh brain when
it comes to food he's so partying he's
his energy he seems so genuine he's he
hope he doesn't get jaded i hope he's
looking i'm telling you he makes me like
molly the meatball a lot are they dating
would you say no no no no no no
they're always together they're training
partners i like her a lot like i like
and i don't i don't mean this wrong but
i don't like i don't follow a ton of
like female fights i just don't yes i
just don't i get it